immaginate di essere negli anni trenta
in un paesino dell'ohio vedete un
lontananza una signora che sta portando
con se un bambino vi avvicinate e
scoprite che si chiama viola allora voi
le ditte
lei sa che sul bambino tra 39 anni
camminerà sulla luna
sicuramente riprenderebbe dalmati ebbene
oggi quando voi andate in giro
potete incontrare il primo uomo che
camminerà su marte perché il primo uomo
e camminerà su marte è sicuramente è già
tra noi non sappiamo bene quando c'è
qualcuno che prevede che il primo sbarco
su marte avverrà nel 2024 altri più
prudentemente parla nel 2036 2037 l'uomo
sicuramente arriverà su marte in tempi
ragionevoli la colonizzazione della luna
e di marte sono i primi passi verso la
creazione di una civiltà interplanetaria
una civiltà in cui l'uomo avrà sempre
centro della sua civiltà sulla terra ma
potrà vivere lavorare creare cultura
anche in altri posti e questi posti
inizialmente saranno la luna e marte
sulkowski diceva la terra è la culla
dell'umanità ma l'uomo non può vivere
sempre nella culla
qui abbiamo un'immagine di marte
un'immagine di uno dei posti più belli
di marte se dovessi fare una pubblicità
turistica per marte probabilmente
prenderei questa immagine è un quadro e
fantasia
ovviamente però il posto è vero il posto
è un canyon valles marineris un canyon
talmente grande che il grand canyon del
colorado dentro ci starebbe parecchie
volte tra una ventina d'anni
probabilmente o poco più questa immagine
invece di vederli in un quadro la
potremo vedere in diretta
televisiva marte è un pianeta molto
grande anche se più piccolo della terra
però la terra tanti oceani la terra
vivibile di marte è più o meno la stessa
estensione dei continenti terrestri
bisognerà andare su marte studiarlo
esplorarlo e poi si potrà colonizzarlo
forse addirittura terrà a formarlo cioè
renderlo usabile diciamo così da uomini
senza tuta spaziale senza particolari
tecnologie
qui abbiamo un over cioè un veicolo per
marte questa immagine tratta da un film
di questo è un frutto di fantasia anche
se io credo che saranno molto più simili
ai veicoli che usiamo sulla terra che
non ha questo oggetto questa capsula è
un re dragons e chi la costruisce pensa
che potrà fare il primo atterraggio su
marte nel giro di 3 4 anni
naturalmente senza equipaggio a bordo
in preparazione poi di un atterraggio
che con uomini a bordo potrà avvenire 56
anni dopo
non è stato realizzato da o per un
agenzia spaziale come la nasa l'agenzia
spaziale russa ma è costruito da una
compagnia privata che si pone lo scopo
della esplorazione di marte altre
compagnie private si pongono lo scopo di
valorizzare e sfruttare mineraria mente
gli asteroidi lo spazio intorno a noi è
piena di risorse di materie prime e
l'umanità
finché sta sulla terra è limitata e
limitata nel suo sviluppo dalla quantità
di materie prime che esistono su questo
pianeta ma quando uscirà da questo
pianeta e crea quella società
interplanetaria allora avrà a
disposizione una quantità tale di
materie prime da permettere di
un'espansione praticamente senza limiti
i limiti ovviamente ci sono e sono dati
a dare distanze se marte è relativamente
vicino la luna in realtà è vicinissimo
astronomicamente parlando sono poi poco
più di 300.000 km quindi è vicinissimo
marte molto più lontana ma se vogliamo
uscire dal sistema solare
le distanze diventano spaventose le
distanze interstellari sono talmente
grandi che oggi con le nostre tecnologie
non possiamo permetterci di mandare
altro che microonde cioè sono molto
piccole con una massa di qualche grammo
in questo caso nella figura ne vediamo
una spinta da una vela che adatta una
microsonda potrà avere delle dimensioni
di un metro 2 o cose del genere
però comunque roba molto piccola le
grandi astronavi interstellari che
vediamo nei film di fantascienza sono
molto lontane nel tempo ovviamente ci
possono volere secoli per svilupparle un
punto importante è che fino a poco tempo
fa si pensava che le stelle doppie o
estere multipli in generale non
potessero avere pianeti e questo è un
grosso problema perché la stella più
vicina a noi alpha centauri è una stella
i pluck allora se alpha centauri non
poteva avere pianeti le stelle più
vicine con pianeti erano sicuramente a
distanze molto maggiori e quindi la
difficoltà dell'esplorazione di questi
pianeti era molto più grande oggi invece
sappiamo che alfa centauri a o perlomeno
è molto probabile che abbia dei pianeti
un pianeta è stato scoperto intorno alla
componente bidia alpha centauri però una
scoperta che alcuni altri scienziati
hanno messo in dubbio quindi non ne
siamo sicuri
recentemente un pianeta è stato scoperto
intorno a proxima centauri prossimo
centauri e la componente di alpha
centauri più vicino a noi se
effettivamente alpha centauri a un
pianeta
vuol dire che abbiamo un pianeta
extrasolare da studiare a solo quattro
anni luce visto che c'è l'interesse per
andarci e oggi si sono le tecnologie per
andarci c'è qualcuno che ha pensato di
mettere su un progetto per mandare mick
rawson e su alpha centauri qui abbiamo
la un'immagine della conferenza stampa
di apertura del progetto brics star shop
l'idea è stata di hawking stephen
hopkins nell'immagine abbiamo per
esempio la seconda persona da destra è
un astronauta americana nei jamison e
altri sono scienziati però nel progetto
ci sono anche degli imprenditori
zuckerberg e milner che promettono di
finanziare questo progetto il progetto
si deve occupare di tutti i problemi
legati alla costruzione al lancio al
controllo di questa microsonda io per
esempio personalmente mi occupo della
stabilità del sistema vela micro
microsonda un problema che avevamo già
affrontato da anni perché progetti del
genere però senza l'incentivo di un
pianeta intorno alpha centauri vengono
circa la metà degli anni 80 ed erano
stati lanciati da un altro grande
scienziato americano che bob forward il
quale aveva fatto un progetto per queste
micro sonde però allora le micro
tecnologie hanno molto più arretrate
si pensava che fosse una cosa ancora per
un futuro lontano quindi si vuole
arrivare ad alpha centauri con un volo
di soli 20 anni
per farlo bisogna viaggiare a un quinto
della velocità della luce che una
velocità terribilmente elevata ma con
quella vela e una batteria di laser di
potenza che la spinge con i suoi raggi
di luce ci si può arrivare
si può arrivare a raggiungere un quinto
della velocità della luce è arrivare su
alpha centauri nel sistema di alpha
centauri in una ventina d'anni
qui nell'immagine abbiamo questi laser
di potenza posizionati sulla terra il
che li crea un po dei problemi perché i
raggi laser devono passare attraverso
l'atmosfera probabilmente mettendo la
stessa batteria sulla luna le cose
sarebbero molto più efficienti però il
progetto è partito ci sono tantissime
cose da risolvere
probabilmente ci vorranno 20 o 30 anni
per poterlo mettere in pratica
e poi altri 20 anni per arrivare su
alpha centauri
ma questo vuol dire che in 40 anni in 40
anni non dimentichiamo che
la colonizzazione della lune di marte
saranno già iniziati per andare a
studiare un pianeta extrasolare poi
sicuramente ci vorrà moltissimo tempo
perché si avveri quello che vediamo nei
film di fantascienza uomini che vadano a
colonizzare questi pianeti ma la civiltà
interplanetaria è iniziata e l'uomo
comincia a espandersi nello spazio